un fab lab destiné aux étudiants aux
entrepreneurs ou aux particuliers à
prendre ensemble l'objectif de ce
nouveau lieu qui ouvre ses portes dans
l'ancienne école maternelle
albert camus à trappes l'état d'esprit
d'un fab lab c'est de se dire qu'on est
tous capables d'acquérir des compétences
de les partager aussi c'est un lieu de
partage de façon gratuite des intéressés
et de fabriquer ensemble fabriqués grâce
à des matériaux recyclés le skylab est
une association qui met à disposition de
ses adhérents des outils et des machines
en échange d'une cinquantaine d'euros
le site consiste en quatre salles avec
tout d'abord un atelier couture une
salle informatique dans lequel on va
pouvoir faire des formations une salle
qui est dédiée à l'impression 3d et à la
découpe laser et enfin une dernière
salle qui est dédié à tout ce qui est
électronique pour faire de la robotique
de la réparation de matériel etc
le principe est également de réutiliser
du matériel pour éviter de jeter plutôt
que de les jeter à la déchetterie ou à
la poubelle on peut recycler on peut
réutiliser on peut réparer aussi et
sortir un peu de la logique on le vit
avec le black friday du tout
consumérisme d'arrêter d'acheter achetez
achetez jeter au bout de quelques mois
le site propose également des ateliers
informatiques ou de couture